I am so happy that I did this because I  grew up with you and this is such a trip  well thank you I'm a big fan I was a  curious kid I was the youngest of my  family and like there's [ __ ] lying  around and you consume it you know Ryan  like my parents were never super like  sheltering also I read chunks of  definitely saw private parts when I was  like really little and it was like  formative I genuinely was like I  remembered like the image of like you on  the cover I just fully remember being  like what is that like I saw the movie  on TV I definitely but I remember  reading parts of the book too and it was  like I really enjoyed it thought it was  like I was extremely curious and like  yeah I know and I was like way too young  but at the same time like I turned out  fine and but it was just a super  developmental is what I'm saying  seriously like it was a thing oh yeah  don't blame me if you're seeing a  psychiatrist